[Music]
there is rising outrage this morning
over a no-knock police search in
minneapolis that led to a deadly
shooting by swat team officers police
video of the raid was released yesterday
we must warn you it is disturbing to
watch
22 year old amir lock was lying on the
couch when officers burst in as part of
a murder investigation police say he
pointed a gun at the officers and was
shot but the city's interim police chief
say locke was not the man the officers
were looking for jericho duncan is
following the investigation in the
demand for answers from locke's family
tarika good morning good morning to all
of you
activists demanded the release of this
body cam footage after wednesday
morning's raid the minneapolis police
department has been under scrutiny for
years but the department was put under
the national spotlight of course in may
and 2020 after the killing of george
floyd this latest incident is igniting
calls to put an end to no knock warrants
where officers can enter the premises
without notifying residents
body cam video shows minneapolis swat
officers turning a key into the door of
apartment 701 at the bolero flats just
after 6 30 wednesday morning officers
enter and can be heard shouting with
guns drawn as they approach 22 year old
amir lock lying on the couch wrapped in
a blanket
a gun can be seen in lock's hand just
before officers opened fire only about
nine seconds after entering the
apartment
the police department says locke pointed
the gun in the direction of the officers
officer mark hannemann fired three shots
two of them hitting lock in the chest
and one in the wrist lock was later
pronounced dead at the hospital
minneapolis interim police chief amelia
huffman says swat officers were
executing both a knock and no knock high
risk search warrant in a homicide
investigation the officer had to make a
split-second decision
to assess the circumstances
and determine whether he felt like there
was
an articulable threat huffman says locke
was not named in the search warrant and
it's unclear if he is connected to the
homicide investigation huffman also
confirmed officers recovered items that
they believe are related to the case
civil rights lawyer ben crump is
representing the family and in a
statement compared the shooting to the
botched raid where police serving a
no-knock warrant killed briana taylor in
her home in louisville kentucky in 2020
saying in part this is yet another
example of why we need to put an end to
these kinds of search warrants so that
one day black americans will be able to
sleep safely in their beds at night if
you're doing a no-knock warrant you want
to be stealthy you want to enter before
the people realize that you're there
professor of law at the university of
saint thomas mark osler people's empathy
is going to lie
with the eyes that they see it through
if you see it through the eyes of the
people entering the room in blue
you're going to be thinking about that
gun that could kill you
if you see it through the eyes of the
person lying on the couch who's suddenly
awakened and there's people rushing
towards you
that's going to be a very different
perspective
locke's family and attorney ben crump
will be holding a news conference later
this morning locke did not have a
criminal record in minnesota and his
family says he had a permit for the gun
activist groups are calling for officer
hanneman to be arrested and charged with
murder he is now on administrative leave
pending an investigation into the
incident and keep in mind you all we
only saw about nine to ten seconds of
video right so it's unclear if ben crump
and the family have seen more than that
but of course uh we expect to learn more
at that news conference today yeah i saw
a freeze frame of the gun and it
appeared to be pointing down but again
that's a freeze frame if you're a police
officer rushing into a situation you see
a gun you don't say is it up is it down
right and but it's so troubling to me
because you russian the guy is sleeping
on the couch he doesn't know what is
happening he has a gun and i think in
his mind maybe he's trying to protect
himself or somebody breaking into the
house there's still so many details a
lot of questions i mean the professor
put it in really great context he really
did what eyes you see it through the
police or the person in the building and
also there's a third set of eyes the the
family of this murder victim that they
were apparently seeking justice for um
you know so
that does dictate how you feel about
what we do know is a man is dead who
they weren't looking for yes which is
unfortunate exactly indeed
maybe it is time to totally rethink
those no knocks seriously i don't know
why we can't just wait till they come
out of the building or create a
different checklist before before you go
in yeah it's very troubling very
troubling thank you
we know you'll stay on it thank you